if you get a chance and you're in las
vegas
and you go to the link that's correct
hotel um he has his own showroom there
uh nightly you can see matt franco what
is the name of the show matt franco
tough to remember no but sometimes
there's a like isn't there an underlying
magic reinvented nightly
okay
so that's what he only does one show you
can go every night because each night it
is reinvented let's ask kimmy kimmy
actually has gone yeah kimmy who works
with us in development kimmy's gone so
many times jimmy how many times have you
seen the show you can come talk to the
mic how many times have you seen the
show
i'm embarrassed to say but i'd say maybe
between 20 and 30. no way
you know matt thinks she's a big fan but
when she's here yeah after she comes
home she's learning all the tricks and
eventually she's going to enroll in agt
and kimi hemar inventing magic nightly
uh
but uh
but uh can you hear in your headsets
somebody's asking
i think he didn't need to type that it's
super loud so i'm like halfway okay yeah
so we'll turn it down okay thanks so
we'll turn it down and you know because
that's really low rather than you're
they're turning yours
down
is that better um is that better no it's
super loud is that better it's still
super loud is this better getting louder
now it's muted now it's muted yeah i
didn't want to mention anything because
i didn't know we were going to do like a
tech meeting in the middle it's not
muted we have made the sound
my son alex is on the uh he's on the
dial this podcast is reinventing a
number pick a number
pick a number
from between 1 and 22. got it pick it i
picked it all right
what is it
seven wrong
should i take off my clothes what does
that mean it's just wrong
all right he can do those he's been
practicing okay a long time what was it
19. ah okay
so
and for those at home that are listening
that got the number right uh email us at
uh where do they where they send it no
they have to send it to write a comment
on our reviews on apple podcast or write
a comment if they're watching it on
youtube
in the comment section only the people
that got the number right right okay so
i went to see i don't i forget what i
was talking about but i went to see your
show and i've seen a lot of shows i love
i think it's like the best magic show
i've ever seen and i loved i i don't
know if you're still because i haven't
seen you in a couple of years
well maybe i haven't seen you in nine
apparently i'm not
good at figuring it out he just came
back to the show
no no no i'm talking about his one-man
show that he does in vegas okay and it
was brilliant and i'll tell you it was
brilliant thematically what i remember
you know most people go and watch magic
and uh you you talk about this there's
two schools of thought sure and one
being that people go there and enjoy the
magic and the mystery and the the uh the
beauty of this performance and they want
to be odd and they want to be surprised
and then there's the people that watch
it and go i i know how you do that oh
you know what he did he did that and
that's kind of like ruining it like why
is that fun
like guess where the loogie just came
from yeah
he's just not taking any more guesses
with lou he just he just made it appear
like that anyway nothing up my nose
but but what you uh talk about very
eloquently in the act is saying unless
you want to be a magician like kimmy
yes
like a kid
or like you know just sit back and enjoy
it right and there's no reason to pick
it apart i just want to know how it's
done
i just want to know how it's done and
then when when they pull back the
curtain and i you know i'll google it or
look it up and see how it's done i'm i'm
always
feel like such a sucker
that it was see i hate that fool i hate
that i hate that i hate that i hate that
people want to do it just enjoy it
that's like i do enjoy why don't you sit
and watch me
write my joke and figure out before you
hear my joke and you can laugh that
would be very very this is all a
misnomer though it's a common
misconception that when you learn the
secret it ruins the trick it's not true
for me what do you mean it's not true
it's not true because if you go a step
further you appreciate it more that's
what i think
what's the next step i'm thinking well
who enjoys magic the most in this room
probably me right i'm obsessed with it
my whole life i i do it all day right
right
i know how all the tricks work
right
but what is the is the joy but but also
not only that the the
there's so much to dexterity dexterity
you know the things you can do with your
fingers and how you hide things and how
you manipulate and how you pull
somebody's focus to something else right
it's a skill oh yeah and not only that
skill to me it's like the same skill i
know nothing about music but like a
drummer i'm fascinated that a drummer
that each hand is doing a different
thing each foot is doing a different
thing right at the same time as you know
and i'm saying the stupid but it's the
same time as you being able to flip a
quarter behind your finger so i can't
see it at that same moment you are
telling me a story right
and and that story is pulling my focus
to something else so i don't see what
you're doing with your foot when you
hide it under your foot right you know
that's amazing it's like oh and and my
best analogy to that is when you watch
somebody who's a good dancer
i don't want to know how they do that i
just want to watch it and stand back i
don't have to try to do that right right
right right yeah you don't want to see
the pain that they're feeling but you're
constantly on instagram sure everything
you're constantly doing like even in
your house you know you're practicing
and doing things and
love magic everybody loves men there's
not a person alive that is not
fascinated i believe from magic whether
you're three or 100 which is why there's
so many magicians that end up winning
agt right isn't this is this like no but
we see a lot of we see a lot of bad
magic that's true right i love bad magic
well there was somebody that was on our
show that that was their act
where they were purposely doing but i
think they were a really good magician
who knew how to do things
badly
and maybe i'm wrong but
bad magic
purposefully is good absolutely bad
magic by accident is like bad comedy i
used to do a bad man i used to have the
magic rings
uh-huh you know you buy the magic rings
there's five of them and three of them
are connected right and i used to try to
separate the three that are connected
okay and keep tugging at him
and i get
my punchline was i got to keep
practicing i couldn't
i was just a long time pulling and
pulling
[Music]
you